Former acting attorney general
Sally Yates testified
before Congress today
regarding ousted
national security advisor
Michael Flynn's alleged ties
to Russia.
Flynn resigned less than a month
into his term
in revelations
he'd lied about meetings
with Russian ambassador
Sergey Kislyak, who...
God, this is really boring.
Jack, um, do we have that raw
adult dodge ball video instead?
-(laughter)
-Aw!
-Man.
-(applause and cheering)
That really livened up
the intro.
-Ah!
-(whooping)
Right in the lady balls.
-You could hear it.
-(laughter)
Anyway, Flynn formerly headed
President Obama's
Defense Intelligence Agency
before being fired in 2014
due to mismanagement,
temperament issues
and reportedly destroying
the Lincoln bathroom.
-(laughter) -And today,
sources revealed
Obama personally warned Trump
to stay away from Flynn.
Maybe that is the warning
happening right there, or maybe
it's the "Not my (bleep) problem
any more, bro."
-Kind of a thing there.
-(laughter)
-(applause and cheering)
-I don't know.
But...
I'll tell you, if we know
anything about Trump,
it's that nothing
dissuades him more
than telling him
not to do something.
So comedians, what's another
warning President Obama
gave
to incoming President Trump?
April Richardson.
If you want to score weed from a
Supreme Court justice, remember,
Ruth Bader Ginsburg's
got the good (bleep).
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
Points. -(laughter, applause)
Mark Normand.
If you want to win people over,
kill Osama bin Laden.
Oh, wait. I already did that.
-(laughter)
-Points.
(applause)
Dweezil Zappa.
You're not a civilian anymore,
so you might want
to avoid Twitter.
-HARDWICK: Yeah, points.
Points. -(laughter, applause)